I'm joined by the chair of the British
Youth Council Amanda Chetwynd Carson
Yaya Mia who is a six form pupil at
Bolingbroke Academy in southwest London
youth worker dummy Halloran ISA Moe and
Kat Smith Shadow Minister for voter
engagement and young people very good
evening to you all now so much to talk
about and on so many fronts the outlook
is fairly bleak for a generation C
generation kovat if we can call you that
let's start with you Amanda and talk
about education good education is of
course the Gateway to a future just tell
us about your fears I think overall one
of my main fears around education and
young people is their complete and utter
lack of a plan about what to do it's
been over 80 days since schools in
England were closed and there's just so
many opportunities for the government to
have really listened to young people to
teachers into institutions to actually
make sure that young people are involved
in the planning of how to bring
education back safely because we all
know it's quite well documented that if
that isn't done it's going to be the
people from the most deprived
backgrounds who really who really feel
the effects of this for the longest and
I think it's just absolutely
unacceptable that the government haven't
even produced a contingency plan for
what happened if they weren't able to
open schools they've had plenty of time
to do that they knew that was always a
possibility the moment they closed
schools so I think there's a real fear
here that actually it's going to be the
children from the most difficult
backgrounds who get properly left behind
for a long long time many many years to
catch up again yeah and just stay with
you Amanda the issue of universities as
well those that want to go there and
those that are already there missed
quite a lot of teaching yeah exactly and
I think again that's another element
where what we really needed was a clear
bit of leadership from the government
and there's been no kind of advice to
the sector as a whole to handle even the
most basic of issues the fact that many
university students were paying rent in
a house that they actually literally
could not move into they had to pay rent
in halls there was no guarantees around
contextual applications for people who
have just finished school and going to
university so again the one thing for me
that really stands out here is the
complete and utter lack of any planning
from the government to make sure that it
not pupils from the most deprived
families in the long term yeah yeah
let's hear from you because we saw you
talking to Inzamam there about well you
should still be at school you should be
doing your a-levels shouldn't you just
about coming to the end of them or maybe
have finished them of course you'll not
just tell us about your experience over
the last three months well over the last
three months because of of course you
always used to waken up in the morning
following the same routine having
breakfast going to school meeting your
friends and your teachers but it's been
a complete drastic change of like tithe
almost and teachers have like I thought
we had a huge impact on that they've
changed lessons online I've had a lot of
pastoral care with teachers visiting
dropping food packages it's been utterly
amazing and at the same time has been
extremely difficult because the events
of Crone are so unpredictable so you're
not sure whether how much you need to
work how much you need to focus on your
studies for uni and it's just that
unpredictability which is the largest
fear at the moment within these last
three months I just tell us again about
your ambitions what you want to study
and where I'd like to study job for you
with a year board either Bristol or
Primera's University of course a big
part of that is that it has a year
abroad which is the biggest inside see
once again because you don't know what's
gonna happen with that year abroad and
one of the main things which made me
want to choose that is sort of learning
about the world learning about people
and the source systems and flows were on
that and now Coronas it you know you're
not sure what what study I'm not sure
whether to read ahead it's it's it's a
very confusing time for me okay well
let's talk to you dami as a youth worker
and amanda was mentioning there are a
lot of people you work with were we're
already struggling educationally before
this yeah yeah I think exams are a very
difficult time for young people all
across the country across the globe and
to have obviously you basically prepare
for them the majority of your life as a
young person when you're in school
everything sort of builds up to this
time period where you have to obviously
do you exam
and so for for you to have to cancel
your exams for a global pandemic so not
only is your meet your future under
scrutiny your exams as well that that is
what you're aiming for a young person
that's the ultimate goal that you're
trying to achieve and for that to be
phone basically out the window and not
being sure about the grade you're going
to get how you're going to get them it's
a scary time for a lot of young people
was difficult for them to be able to
handle that especially when a lot of
young people are waiting and the term
and wait for the exams to maybe boost
their grades up a little bit more work a
little bit harder and maybe their school
but hasn't been able to get them the
grade that they need to get into their
university either the quality that
they're trying to get into let me ask
you a specific question now we knew
before this about exclusion from schools
and how damaging that can be well in a
sense everyone's being excluded is that
you think further down the line going to
cause a lot of problems yeah I think
it's sort of it's just telling young
people to sort of take ownership of
their their learning which for some
young people has been really difficult
and some young people really require the
the change of setting the environments
the support of the of the support of the
teachers and the people in the community
around them to basically help them get
through studying or focusing and so with
everyone obviously not being in that
setting not having that same sort of
flow the pattern routine that you're
used to it's very easy easy for you to
fall off and slap it's very easy for you
not to finish the module that you had to
complete and it's difficult for teachers
and especially to be able to enforce
some of the stuff that they're trying to
teach it's difficult for them to get the
same expression just see if a young
person needs that extra support extra
motivation is it's hard for everybody in
sort of the education on the support
sectors to be able to help young people
in that way it's even more difficult for
them to internally motivate themselves
to do that especially when they have no
sort of support or enforcement basically
Kat Smith give us the politicians view
now heard Amanda they're calling crying
out for a plan for young people's
education why don't you get together why
isn't there a kind of government of all
the time
it's a committee of all the talents to
work something out well I'm under said I
mean I couldn't disagree with with
anything that she said I thought the
points that she raised on actually the
other panelists as well
I'm absolutely raised the issue and I
think that already this discussion has
got into a broader space than we often
get into and when we're politicians have
been interviewed on programs like like
your own if I might say about the issues
about education which is beyond
education so the issues around and the
way in which exams graduations school
leaving completing apprentice really
punctuated a young person's life and
help them to build on to the next stage
and all of that has been M ripped apart
so I do think that there needs to be a
plan from government I think it needs to
be a plan that looks beyond education
and a plan that actually looks at your
uncle as a whole sorry to interrupt Kath
Smith but you know it's the urgency of
it all we need the plan now absolutely
but that plan has to be a plan that can
work and and all the way through labor
is trying to be a constructive
opposition we have always managed to
highlight the issues and the potential
pitfalls that a government might be
about to walk into and and that's the
role that we play so I've already called
on the but to take that approach to make
sure that young people have been looked
at in a very holistic way but we're not
just talking about how do we get schools
opened actually how do we bring in the
extra mental health support that we know
young people are going to need when they
get back into those schools how do we
actually rebuild the youth work set
around which has been decimated for this
government to give that wraparound
support outside of the school
environment because if you don't look at
young people as a whole just think
you're gonna stop crisis but its
generation spacing I think we pretty
much know the questions we haven't got a
lot of answers yet but yeah I want to
ask you do you feel that you your
generation had just been overlooked by
the politicians you aren't part of the
planning I wouldn't particularly say
what being overlooked but I definitely
think there's not the attention nuts
there and that's supposed to be shown
you know like she said it all starts in
the youth centers the youth pubs in my
local area there's baseball carnies
community which is a small boxing club
which help youth and young children like
me out of sorbet state basis and really
gets them to be a part of a family and
things like that and I think it's really
important to have that have that support
there and I think especially in this
time where aces like that oppose and
there's not enough support be insurance
children like of my generation
especially it really affects stuff like
mental health and so physical well-being
to with the sport like boxing
dami you you see the the damage that a
sense of alienation can cause to society
people young people who feel well this
society doesn't speak for me it doesn't
represent me my needs or my beliefs
could this only make it worse yeah a
hundred percent I think disillusion and
distrust with the government and the
authorities and people that are around
us
really it affects young people I think
when we start to distrust the people
that are meant to support us and care
for us it becomes very difficult for us
that's where you start to see young
people start to potentially act out or
became anti socially I don't think that
it mmm I don't think that's easy for
young people to be in the situation and
obviously without any proper support in
any care and I need for given by our
government it's difficult for the the
per except to the youth sector to
support and care for young people and
carry this way well let's let's move on
now and join it up and Amanda move on
into the the world of work employment
and that's supposed to talk cause we
haven't got an unlimited amount of time
the two forms of work though the forms
of work that a lot of young people will
do to to fund them during their
education a lot of those jobs just gone
or will be gone and then those first
steps on the ladder of employment of
valued and valuable employment tell us
your thoughts Amanda
so I guess kind of like you said it's
kind of twofold and the first one is
that I don't think there's been a real
appreciation of how much students and
teaching people in college its that
should really depend on the retail and
the hospitality sector for that first
job and often actually for that first
bit of kind of independence and
financial security and I appreciate this
being a lot of conversations around jobs
being lost but there's not really been a
focus on what age group is going to
mostly lose out from that and it is kind
of young people in particular but on the
second point again around the kind of
entry-level jobs there has just been no
planning from this government I've not
seen anything from them around how they
intend to really dramatically drive up
the number of supported apprenticeships
they're gonna do and how you can really
incentivize different organizations and
businesses to make sure that actually
those apprenticeships are offered to
people from areas high level of
deprivation areas there's been no kind
of real conversations around what's
happened to any of the people who have
already had their apprenticeships
cancelled I've met some members from the
British Youth Council who were supposed
to start apprenticeships in the next
couple of months and in September those
apprenticeships have being cancelled and
they've been told hopefully your
University who can make it work and
you'll lose that year in industry and
you can just deal with the modules that
are there and that's not really what
these people signed up for and again
it's taking away that agency from young
people's lives where actually they're
making decisions about what they want to
do with their employment and mature
career sorry I've just got a but in a
manner and ask you I mean you are on the
British Youth Council are you not being
consulted I mean surely your voice in
the very heart of government is
essential it's not really interesting to
me about who has and who hasn't reached
out to byc and to other organizations
for consultation the Bank of England
over 900 young people worked with our
Bank of England Youth Forum to give
their experiences and their economic
concerns relating to Kovach directly to
the chief economist it's not hard if
something as old and institutional as
the Bank of England can consult young
people on their economic concerns from
co-head
I refuse to believe the Department for
Education DCMS
all other departments from the
government can't consult young people
but we've been advocating and trying and
doing our best to get in there and it's
kind of just waiting for the other side
to come to the table and say let's
actually talk to young people and let's
find out what they really want and what
they're going to need to really succeed
and not get left behind there for the
next few years yo yeah just tell us
about the number of jobs that you were
doing we saw in ins Imams report there
that you've been a highly productive I
was doing three jobs in order to Swartz
my family the main job which was me
working out bread stool little stool
inside North cut road selling foods
people and before coronavirus and they
lock down all the biood I was working
babysitting with kids in the area and
also a place will flip out which is a
little trampoline place for likes
orchids too and it was really helping my
family and obviously with me now not
being able to have those two other jobs
and only being able to work read store
and that that one sole job and obviously
my brothers being burned it really does
affect my family and it really does
affect the income which comes in and out
really and career-wise you mentioned you
want to study geography what would you
ideally like to go on to do I'm not sure
I don't think I think it's a good thing
being on sure and I'd like to see where
it takes me and I'd like to see where
I'd go with it however is something I
was interested in and something which I
hope leads me to your places
yeah fair play to you dami the question
is if they if they clearly aren't high
quality or decent jobs let's just stick
with that decent jobs fairly well-paid
jobs around for young people well then
there is some of them are going to try
and find money elsewhere yeah 100
percent 100 percent it's difficult to
tell a young person to go and work for
five pounder our because as you say we
are situation is difficult to support
your phone being that way however young
people I believe that as a group of
young people someone young myself we're
resilient we are going to try our best
to not just obviously turn to the
typical avenues that we'll see an
advertiser young people but we'll try
and find our way
to best support ourselves within the
means that we have already
I do believe a lot of young people it
may be telogen to see a way out and
working at a low-paying retail job or
low-paying job that you don't
necessarily enjoy that isn't in your
sector I can be very difficult to handle
and to bear with which is why some
people get into avenues that we don't
want to see them in and Kat Smith that
leads us to then the quality of the jobs
whatever schemes are put in place they
have to be proper schemes not like some
of the some of them that were around in
the 1980s proper training proper
apprenticeships properly paid and
leading then to something real and
absolutely and young people's wages were
already stagnating before the
coronavirus crisis and this crisis now
is only looking to make things much
worse for their generation in a distance
coronavirus we've seen the city longs 18
to 24 year olds and wage is absolutely
promising and I think well I'm afraid
Kat Smith seems to have frozen there in
the sense that we've lost the sound from
her I tell you what we'll go to a break
now and we'll hear more from Kat Smith
and indeed all our panelists when we
come back do stay with us
welcome back well we're discussing the
prospects for young people after this
pandemic and just before the break you
may have seen the link went down to Kat
Smith Labour's Kat Smith and we were
discussing jobs the jobs market for
young people how they got to be proper
jobs and so you lost me bad maybe
there's a job of work that can be done
improving internet in Lancashire and the
point I was ending on which is this
which we can learn a lot from the 2008
financial crisis what we learned from
that that it was non-graduates who had
just left and full-time education that
were most severely impacted by a
financial crisis in 2008 we know that
the coronavirus crisis is going to be
very similar and if anything worse so we
the government to be focusing efforts on
reaching out to school leavers and
people that have left education but not
necessarily graduates they are going to
be the cohort that will need the most
support from government and to bring in
proper jobs proper apprenticeships to
make sure they're not forgotten okay
well let's move on now to I suppose an
intangible life experiences and yeah I
want to talk to you about that first of
all and we mentioned there you're not
doing your a-levels they're gonna be
sent you in August with the grades
you're gonna get them so I mean when it
first was announced did you think wow
great I don't have to sit all those
exams or do you now feel yeah you're
missing out on what's called a rite of
passage put in that huge amount of
effort and then you're free to celebrate
for a bit honestly I was very
disappointed that exams were cancelled
because as sort of like people say and
teachers save those last four months of
the most important months where a kid
and especially boys in the sense will
really grind out and try to get the best
way they possibly can with me working
hard those two years and then finding
out that the end result is cancelled it
does preferrence you that en products
will be simple calculated grade really
and with the second thing you asked
about that's all social aspect in the in
the come of the two years we had a
little protect group and we were
planning
was bortles the envy of a celebration to
wrap up the last years of hard work and
with that now being canceled is it's
obviously hard to find new ways where we
can find a celebration where we can
maybe hang out with each other however I
don't think it's all doom and gloom
there are some positives about it
we I do still have for example based on
polls with my mates with my girlfriend
where we learned in hobbies learn to do
new things so I think although this is a
negative situation there are still many
positives to take aspect great here that
di a glass-half-full man there but dummy
you know whether or not you leaving
school going to university or whatever
it's summer for goodness sake and for
young people is no going around people's
houses no hanging out together well
there probably is but not officially and
there certainly aren't things like
festivals and the rest of these these
important experiences yeah yeah
definitely I think a lot of my friends a
lot of people were looking forward to an
immense that Wireless Afro nation
Notting Hill kind of one obviously not
being able to experience these things
puts a downer in yourself I think the
time when you finish school you get on
exams and you have that summer holidays
often some of the best times the young
people have they're relatively
stress-free for a lot of people there go
in to apply for jobs for the first time
they're getting their first job there's
a lot of buzz and excitement about the
experiences you're gonna have just pack
and be difficult for a young person's
obviously to basically had that same
amount of time if not more and not be
able to do anything not being able to
socialize I'll be able to go out and be
able to enjoy instrument time with each
other especially after you've grinded
for essentially a very long time and
Amanda let's let's talk about mental
health because I suspect an awful lot of
young people aren't as robust on that
front as as you all seem to be there's a
danger isn't there with all this
isolation frustration etc there could be
some awful problems building up behind
the scenes yeah absolutely and I think
it was really and quite stark for me
when I kind of a while ago saw the
research from young minds that said
51% of the people that they heard had
filled out this research for them and
they felt that Kovac 19 had actually
made their mental health worse and for
just over 30 percent had made a
significant amount worse and I think one
of the big kind of problems that's
coming around the corner is that a lot
of mental health situations get picked
up in that educational environment
whether that's a university school
college or even primary school and
unless the funding and the resources are
really kind of ramped up when people are
eventually allowed back to school those
services that already really stretch
they're just going to be completely
overwhelmed and that's another area
where I just think actually what young
people probably need to hear and what
particularly parents need to hear as
well is that the government are being
proactive about what it's going to look
like in September and how they are going
to help families and young people really
digest the amount of change and
uncertainty that they've had to live
through recently but we've not seen any
of that and I hope that that's coming
I'll be pleasantly surprised but I do
think we maybe underestimate how many of
those issues get picked up in an
educational setting and as you say
something the government should be
discussing we did ask people on from the
Department for education but they
weren't able to furnish a minister for
us this evening but Kath Smith from
labor is here and just take that on
board we've been talking about the
problems forming relationships the life
experiences the young people are missing
and of course the mental health damage
absolutely and in addition to that
mental health point I would just like to
make point there's not being major which
is for a lot of young people and
lockdown may have been locked down in
somewhere that's not safe so they may
have been knocked down in a home where
there is violence or abuse and they
weren't able to access the preps usual
channels of support that they were using
in addition to that course it might be
the first time a young person has
experienced loss of a close family
member and given the situation we've had
with limited numbers at funerals dying
person might not have had the
opportunity to to attend a funeral and
be able to say goodbye and get position
in that sense so when we come out of
lockdown I think it's important that the
child and adolescent mental health
services that have been so hopefully
underfunded
for the past days I see and really from
that service make sure we sorry cats me
that terribly sorry we are out of time
may I genuinely say the best of luck to
you all and thank you so much for
speaking to us this evening on Sky News
tonight an absolutely fascinating
discussion